[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to our
webcast MBA student insights a Q&A with
GSB pride my name is Eddie boys ER and
I'm a first year MBA student here at the
Stanford Graduate School of Business and
a co-president of GSB pride and I'm
joined here by Duke Tran Vince you and
Jack Armstrong and like me they're also
current MBA students and GSB pride club
members we'll be talking about our
personal journey to the GSB the LGBTQ
experience here on campus and the GSB
pride Club and community and we're going
to try to answer as many of your
questions as we can to submit a question
to us you can click on the Q&A button at
the bottom of your screen and we won't
be talking about the admissions process
the application or financial aid but you
can contact the MBA admissions office
directly by emailing MBA admissions at
GSB dot stanford.edu so before we begin
it would be great if we can begin with
some introductions to Duke Vince and
Jack if you can start by telling us a
little bit more about yourselves where
you're from what you were doing before
coming to the GSB and what your goals
are after graduation that would be great
so Jack do you wanna start hi yep so
Jack originally from the UK first time
living in the u.s. before school I was a
turnaround and restructuring consultant
so working with distressed businesses
hoping to figure out what I want to do
after school I think it looks something
like working with private equity funds
in their portfolio teams but but still
working on it Vince hi I'm Vincent you I
was born and raised in the Philippines I
grew up there I studied there all my
life and prior to coming to the GSB I
was an oil and gas salesman in the
Philippines and thereafter I was in
consulting and with Bain and Singapore
what I plan to do after the GSB I'm
actually a sponsored student by Bain so
I'm heading back but I'm joining their
San Francisco office
hi I'm Duke originally from San Jose
California so just down the street prior
to the GSB I lived in DC for six years
in government and in international
development and post GSP still figure
now but probably somewhere in consulting
or tech yeah and I could just wrap up
with myself
I'm originally from North Jersey I grew
up in Hasbro tightest New Jersey in
Bergen County before the GSB I was
working in New York City at Bain &
Company like Vince and I worked my
fourth year in the Paris office after
graduation I am a sponsor student as
well and I'll be going back into
consulting in New York and for the long
term still trying to figure that out
so just to kick off the first question
what is the LGBTQ community like at the
GSB and what about the campus at large
and what kinds of support involvement
and interaction does the rest of the
class have with the GSB Pride community
so Jack and Vince do you want to kick
that one off sure yeah so I think the
the community of the GSB has been
fantastic I know for me personally it's
the first time I've really engaged in
the community and didn't really prior to
school and so for me it's been really
warm really welcoming I'm very friendly
I think what's nice is the relationship
between the MBA one class in the MBA to
class and kind of turning up on campus
and having some friendly faces to the
community and also I think the kind of
allied ship that you see in the class
more broadly yeah definitely I would
like I'd like to stress on the Isle a
ship because having grown up in
Southeast Asia it was just like
relatively more conservative than the
Bay Area it's definitely been quite
refreshing how accepting everyone's been
and how many allies are in class it's as
if like and again like coming from a
place where my identity is almost
attacked on TV on a daily basis and like
moving to a place where you know it's
just celebrated is very refreshing that
in degeus being also like in the campus
at large yeah thanks and building off
that point can you guys talk about your
experiences specifically with GSB pride
can you talk about some of the social
events that pride organizes throughout
the year
any other types of events that private
sponsors or organizes so I might throw
that one to you Duke and then Jack as
well sure I mean I've lived I loved the
prank group here I think pride is really
what you make of it so we meet up about
once a week just to hang out and catch
up with each other both classes which is
as just mentioned a really valuable
thing for me we also do alumni reception
we have an alumni reception once a year
we attend Rhambo which is the LGBT
conference in the fall we do National
Coming Out Day I think we host informal
small group dinners and that we where we
get to film one another so lots of it
that's throughout the year yeah I think
what's really nice is the touch point of
that kind of weekly social event that we
have it's just a nice way of coming
together you can bring allies you can
bring friends and and people just get
together and sit and sometimes you talk
politics much of which I don't
understand there's a break time trying
to avoid it
but then everything from that through
things going on in the community or
school more broadly and it's just a nice
space to be able to get together and in
a no-pressure environment once a week
which is nice do either you have a
favorite GSB pride event from this past
year that is especially memorable to you
I think the alumni event was was
fantastic I think you realize that
they're not only rock stars in their
lives but then like rock stars in terms
of what they've done for the community a
lot of them which is fantastic to see
them and for them to just be so open to
getting to know us and helping and
supporting I think I was great for me
yeah for me I really enjoyed brahmbhatt
in the fall it was a great you know
first event for entering students got to
know a bunch of my classmates and met a
bunch of new people from different
schools great so talking a little bit
more about what the GSB life is and how
that intertwines with the GSB pride
community can a few of you talk about
your involvement in social and
professional clubs other than GSB pride
so Vince do you want talk about your
experiences sure so I'm a co-president
of two clubs currently first is
co-president of the game Club which is
basically just a bunch of geeks getting
together talking about video games
pursuing video and super set
professional career so that's pretty
great
second is I'm also co-president of the
age of Business Student Association and
what I find is what I find like coming
from Asia and going into you know
foreign country at the u.s. I found that
my idea I never really like appreciated
my attend yet as an Asian until I
actually came to a you know a geography
where which has like a lot of the ethnic
diversity yeah and yeah
that's being part of both GSB pride and
the Asia business dude Association has
helped me appreciate both layers of my
identity the intersectionality between
those two yeah and I guess apart from
that we're also planning a Philippines
global study trip so hopefully that
comes through also I guess I can talk to
that as well for my own experiences so
aside from being in GSB pride I am also
an Arbuckle leadership fellow so the
Arbuckle leadership program is designed
for second-year MBAs and helps second
year MBAs learn how to develop and coach
others and be more effective at coaching
and developing others so we take
specific classes throughout the fall
quarter and the spring quarter now and
in the Fall Quarter when the first year
MBA is arrived we actually take
leadership of a squad of five or six
first-year MBAs and help them develop
them to become better and more effective
leaders through simulated leadership
exercises throughout the quarter so it's
it's a really awesome experience I've
definitely been learning a lot ever
since joining the program and I feel
like I've been developing my leadership
skills in a new and unique way here at
the GSB so shifting away from the pride
community and extracurricular activities
I want to talk a little bit more about
career plans so what are your career
plans and how has your experience at the
GSB helped shape what you might want to
do in the future
I might throw that to you jack to answer
that from first yeah so I think in terms
of how the GSB has helped shape how I
think about career plans I think you're
just surrounded by
800 across the two classes amazing
people who have done a massive range of
interesting things and so I think the
first way it kind of impacted me was it
kind of showed me the art of the
possible in terms of the opportunities
out there you know wells I'd never even
heard of or thought about so I think
that was really powerful just being able
to speak to engage with people and
really dig into what those kind of
opportunities look like and then I think
more broadly the resources on campus so
things like the Career Management Center
is a fantastic resource whether that's
helping you think about what you want to
do which I know I went in with a blank
piece of paper and came out with several
really good options and then they help
you through every step of that process
whether it be interview prep CV reviews
or kind of negotiating internship
opportunities and full-time roles I'm
looking to transition into private
equity and specifically operating within
private equity and lots of our
classmates come from from various firms
and have been really helpful with that
you know in particular several members
of the prior community have put me in
touch with their previous employers or
people that they're in conversations
they then have helped to make that
connection for me yeah how about you
Duke yeah I think my career paths that's
been pretty evolving I echo Jack but the
career services has has been super
helpful in thinking about designing what
your career would be and strategies on
how to engage with alums and even your
professors on how to think about your
career so I came into the GSB thinking
that I wanted to do consulting and I may
still do that but I'm also exploring
tech specifically thinking about whether
or not it make like I would like product
management for example so and I think
that's what's great about the GSB is
like you can talk to people who are
experts in the field and it really
iterate on what you want and what you're
good at and I think just to add on that
I have one specific example of kind of
the community aspect there a couple of
months back there's a company on campus
and the day before I saw one of our
classmates who I'd spoken to about what
I wanted to do and he came up to me and
was just like hey these guys are on
campus tomorrow I've already dropped
them an email to let them know
that you're interested and like this is
your background because he made the
connection between what I wanted to do
and what they were talking about and I
would have totally miss an opportunity
if that hadn't happened
that was totally proactive on their part
so I think I think the community aspect
is really important on that yeah just
like add to the community aspect um I
know I mentioned a while ago that I'm
actually headed back to Bane but I think
what the GSB has helped me figure out is
what I want to do in the long term say
like five to ten years down the line I
also mentioned that I'm part of the game
Club and through the game Club I
actually was able to network with lots
of people for the gaming industry met a
lot of people from you know big
companies like Activision Blizzard EA EA
Games and what thought and really like
these conversations with these different
sorts of people who you know are
passionate in their craft sort of have
inspired me to pursue gaming at least
this summer so this summer what I'm
actually gonna do is I'm gonna be
working as a product manager for a
midsize gaming company in San Francisco
I'm working on a video game called war
dragons
helping create dragons for people who
are gonna play that game on their phone
so that's pretty interesting that's
awesome I want to pick up on a theme
that all of you touched upon which was
your interactions with employers on
campus and how supportive that the pride
community has been in that but talking a
little bit more about your interactions
with employers can you speak to whether
you were out in your interactions with
them and generally how respect how
receptive have employers been to your
identity and if you can speak to
experiences now or experiences before
the GSB please feel free to so I might
toss that one to you do first yeah for
me like I'm pretty comfortable with
being LGBT and I'm not a lot of people
are so I've always been out at work and
I personally believe that it's important
for me to be able to come to work as my
full self and even on my resume lying I
think I have a line that says like
enthusiastic RuPaul's Drag Race pain
just to make it clear how about you Ben
so I guess like for me it's been a stark
contrast having worked in oil and gas
sales before I was actually told by
boss very early on in my career that
like I couldn't out myself to select
clients just because the arena had to be
like a mofo big and whatnot yeah and my
experience in the Bay Area because I've
been primarily applying for internships
here is that it's it's an like being out
and proud as a non-factor some people
might argue that it might actually be a
put like give you some brownie points
for me a diversity candidate so yeah if
anything being out and proud while
applying to different companies as a GSB
person is a good thing yeah give it a
jack um yeah I think certainly a lot of
the big employers are really good at
engaging with the community and helping
with that kind of process of applying
and I think one of the things that I
notice is that especially if you're
talking to alumni or companies with
alumni at them that they you come with
this brand that's already really
powerful and actually they know so much
about you and they've been part of the
GSB community before so I think has been
really well received in general yeah
yeah thanks for your perspectives on
that one I I'm actually seeing that a
bunch of questions are coming in from
the audience so I want to get me have
some time to answer some of those as
well
so the first question that I'm seeing is
hi team thank you for your time today
you're welcome I was wondering what what
is the women to men ratio in the GSB
pride just asking since you are all men
on the panel today
so that's a great point we do have a
number of women in GSB pride who are
super super active in organizing a lot
of the activities that we do just to
give it an example of the four
presidents this past year three of them
identified as women Alice Jess and Ellen
we have a number of groups a number of
events that occur throughout the year
one of them most recently happened in
San Francisco I believe it was a brunch
that was attended by over 25 plus the
GSB Pride women and alumni from around
the Bay Area so there's a super super
active community I can't give exact
numbers on on the ratio and percentage
right now because they don't know them
off the table
head butt they certainly are a big part
of our community and an important one as
well and then another question that we
got was when applying were you out on
your application could you discuss how
you communicated it does anybody want to
take one of those yeah I can take it I
was definitely out on my application
mostly because I had talked about it in
my essay and what you know coming out
and being from my family's pretty
Catholic and what that how that shaped
me into the person that I am today and I
was involved in a bunch of LGBT
organizations too so I listed those on
my resumes I did the exact thing do dig
in mind what matters most and why is a
talked about equality you know and I
think of course lots of elements of
equality that I was able to weave in
were from you know me being queer in a
very in Southeast Asia yeah so me being
out came out there and of course in your
CV you can communicate it as well how
about you jack were you out in your
application I don't think I was I think
it's just if it feels might my thoughts
on this all you have to be authentic in
your application and if it authentically
fits into your story in your essay or
you know in the other parts of your
essay then it other parts your
application then certainly flag it but
yeah I think it's more about being
authentic to answering the questions
yeah I think that's a great point and
I've gotten this question a couple times
as well from prospective admits our or
my advice every time has been if being
LGBT and if that part of your identity
is a huge part of who you are today
what makes you a great leader and what
makes you a great fit for the GSB then I
would absolutely put it in your essays
or in other parts of your application
what I wouldn't recommend is putting it
in just just to put it in without any
particular reason because that's
something that admissions definitely
tries to tease out is who you are as a
person and what kind of value will you
add to the GSB community
other questions from the audience how
active are the allies when it comes to
defending someone who identifies as
LGBTQ in a bird situation do you have
any interesting situations to share I'll
give you guys a couple moments to think
about that or maybe two the first
question how supportive have you have
you perceived allies to be on campus and
would they come to defend you and in
interesting situations I think so I
think more broadly at the GSB I think
was very rarely a situation where I
could see that happening in any form of
diversity or any situation I don't think
I've seen an argument since being here
unless it's a heated debate in a case or
in the classroom and I'd certainly see
very often people voicing their opinions
or thoughts for support and when
discussing cases or just talking
diversity more broadly so in terms of
Allied ship I think people would
certainly stop in and and certainly are
involved in the community with us more
probably yeah anyone else have anything
to ition like really there's no
situation yeah okay I guess it's just
not an issue yeah I think that's the
general theme that I'm hearing from from
all of you is that it doesn't really
seem to be an issue on on campus that
said we do benefit from being in the Bay
Area we do benefit from being in
California so we can't speak to all you
know all environments everywhere but
certainly at Stanford in Palo Alto
specifically there I've been out and I'm
pretty young I haven't experienced any
issues yeah I would also say I think
there's a healthy discussion I think one
of the things that happens a lot at the
GSB is is a healthy discussion around a
collection of topics whether that be out
your identity whether that be diversity
or politics or career or so I think I've
been in lots of situations where people
are certainly tested and challenged and
ask questions and thought about things
and so I think you see that happening a
lot and I think that's a healthy debate
that we see yeah absolutely and I think
on the lsah point
we have tremendous allies who come to
our pride events all the time and I know
next year Eddie's planning on doing more
formal engagements or Live socials with
the different diversity clubs out there
and with the Woodman and management
group no yeah
do you want to talk a bit about that
yeah so I think and I'm sorry I have to
think about what you were referring to
yeah so we just got elected we just
chose our new leadership this just a
couple weeks ago so we've just been in
the process of putting together our
gender for next year
and one of the things that we're really
focusing on really organizing and adding
into the agenda or more community focus
initiatives and specifically education
focus initiatives not just for GSB pride
but for the broader Stanford and GSB
community I think if there's one thing
that we would wish to do more as jsb
pride members is have the ability to
have open conversations with like other
students within within the the GSB
community we do receive a lot of
questions about how people can be a
better Ally so because of this interest
we've just decided to to have more
events around you know just the casual
lunches but also formal ask me anything
type of events which we plan on
organizing for next year so that's all
in the pipeline and we're really kind of
excited to kick kick off take all that
off so I want to switch gears a little
bit to another audience question that
was more around the lines of how we
chose to come to Stanford versus other
programs and what research we did to
really inform that choice so one
question was during the research phase
of your MBA application journey what
questions did you ask alumni at the GSB
or did you ask in general about other
programs and how did that inform your
decision to choose Stanford over another
program whether it was in the country or
internationally I might throw this one
to you jack because I know personally
you were making this choice yeah I
probably did a slightly unconventional
I definitely didn't plan to do business
school and so kind of a few months
before round one I downloaded the FTS
top ten school lists and kind of started
from there
and outside of the kind of year-round
sunshine that Stanford provides which is
a Britt was really important to me I
think I thought about whatever it was
that I wanted to get in terms of skills
development and then how I think about
and then I thought about how I like to
develop those skills and and for me it
was a lot about how is the course
structured what flexibility do I have in
that and then what's the community going
to be like and I think for me that
turning point was admit weekend when I
kind of was looking at various options
and decided to come to admit weekend and
then I just had this weekend where
everybody I met I was like oh you are my
people and so I think that's a really
important factor that it's hard to test
for through you know websites or
statistics I think for me it's who do I
want to spend two years with and who do
I want to grow with and so that was
really important yeah
do any of you have sort of similar
experiences so I applied to so my
application story was I literally just
applied to the top three schools I got
in a couple of them and ultimately the
choice the choice boiled down to where
my partner and I could you know my
partner and I intended to move to
another country where we could get
married or have kids and it seemed that
Stanford provided the perfect like
environment being in the Bay Area to you
know make the transition easy for us
because one whenever we'd have to fly
back to Manila which is a direct which
is just the direct flight from Sanford
to San Francisco yeah from San Francisco
like that flight would be easily
available one and two you know San
Francisco is known as the gay Mecca so
to speak so that is like like that just
makes the whole transition was easier
for us I can talk about my my own
experience as well so for me I was
really torn in trying to decide between
Stanford or an international school like
INSEAD
one of the benefits of going to an
international school is that you have a
little bit more of an international
focus which is great but at the end of
the day what it boiled down to me was
where did I feel like I could develop
most as a leader and having a two-year
program at Stanford to me kind of tribes
a one-year program at an international
school somewhere else so that's kind of
how I made my choice
even though my my fiancee is French and
definitely wanted to be good to go to
INSEAD had to let him down so switching
gears now into mentorship one question
from the audience is how do you
personally engage with mentors GSB
alumni I know we talked about the alumni
event but are there other avenues that
any of you have experienced with
engaging with any mentors or alumni
through the network I think one of the
things that you get at the GSB is lots
of moments of mentorship that might not
be specifically a mentor so I was
telling the guys just before I came in
that I did a small group dinner with a
faculty member here who is a very
successful VC in the Bay Area and at
that small group dinner offered ups it's
kind of one-on-one conversations and 2-3
weeks later I'm start having coffee for
30 minutes talking about anything that
was on my agenda whether that was
whether I wanted to pitch a startup idea
what whether I wanted to talk about my
career or how to manage the world that
is the GSB that's one example of where
you know that mentorship happens in the
moment I know I think my favorite class
of the first quarter is managerial
skills where basically you get these
rock stars who come in and teach you
basically how to hire people how to fire
people how to manage difficult
conversations and again we did a small
group dinner with our faculty member
there I've had follow-up coffees and
these are people that you know you
couldn't get time with
you tried in the real world and I think
you get lots of moments of small
mentorship which I think you can grow
then into longer-term relationships if
it feels right yeah and I've had a
similar experience as well when I
attended the reaching out and be a
conference this past fall I had met a
GSB Pride alumni there who I didn't know
before at a reception at Google and he
him and I connected immediately after
the reception he was absolutely
instrumental in helping me through the
process and helping me with interviews
helping me with questions so I really
really felt like he he wanted me to
succeed and I think without that GSB
pride connection I'm not sure if I would
have been able to connect with any other
recruiter at the conference because of
that so that's just one example I mean I
think the punch line here is like we
found the alumni really really
supportive even if we only see them you
know a couple times per year at ad-hoc
events you know they're always there for
support I guess we also haven't touched
on is MBA to use as mentors so during
your first year you take this class
called leadership labs in which you're
assigned an Arbuckle leadership fellow
they'll lead you along with a group of
six in like leadership development
exercises where you pick up different
soft skills and whatnot and I found that
to be a very good mentorship tool and in
the to succeeding corridors you can
actually get paired with a personal
leadership coach in the form of an
Arbuckle leadership fellow who will you
know meet up with you seven or eight
times to fulfill whatever leadership
needs you have and for me that was very
powerful because in those specific
moments I had like very like particular
conversations I had to had with regard
to like say trying to extend a job I
trying to like push a job offer or like
for example extend the deadline of a job
offer and whatnot so so that time with
that coach was very valuable and yeah I
guess the wouldn't what what I'm trying
to say is MBA Tuscon serves as mentors
it's service mentors as well and I guess
just to allude to what Jack said I
learned so much from MBA ones who are
seasoned and experienced and different
sorts of like environments and
industries that I may treat them as
mentors for
ticular things in other times like for
certain topics awesome
on that topic of leadership actually
another question submitted by the
audience is what are you learning about
leadership while at the GSB that you
didn't already know and this is a really
really important question so I'd like
for I guess everybody to answer it do
you want to start yeah I mean I think
one thing that I've learned is the power
of like vulnerability in the context of
management that it helps build trust
that it helps folks connect with you
that you are managing or working with I
think that came as a surprise for me
because I don't I'm not naturally
vulnerable but I think that there are
tons of opportunities at the GSP to
practice that muscle and really build
that trust with your classmates and
actually vulnerability was the first
answer that came to my head but because
dig ticket I guess like not leadership
in particular but developing leadership
skills I think what I learned that was
very valuable at the GSB was to immerse
yourself in like situations that like
the what came what came to mind was like
the value of role-playing and whatnot
and basically what I'm alluding to is
how just immerse keep immersing yourself
in like situations that you know you
should think you may experience in the
future that you know you feel like
getting lost keep you like immerse
yourself in situations that you feel
will like help develop your leadership
skills in the future yeah so say for
example in that Arbuckle leadership
class we would roleplay certain things
like firing an employee hiring an
employee I'm having a difficult
conversation with someone like two
layers above and just immersing yourself
in those situations that you could
potentially face in the future
like we'll end up developing those
skills yeah I think one thing you hear a
lot here is that leadership is a set of
behaviors rather than something that is
intrinsic to a specific person so I
think to to build on what Vince is
saying that if you put yourself into
situations where you are able to build
on those behaviors and exercise those
behaviors you will become a better Lee
yeah how are you jack I think for me
it's the lead leadership comes in so
many forms in it's very personal I think
one of the things we talked about this
leadership labs program and basically
the ultimate question is you know why
would somebody follow you as a leader
and at the end of the the course you
basically go round as a team and say why
you would or wouldn't follow everybody
as a leader and no one answers the same
and I think everybody there is a reason
that everybody can be a leader and
there's a there's things that make them
really impactful as a leader and that
might be a variety of things I think you
can take a set of tools a set of
behaviors make it authentic to you and
that's what's going to make you
successful if you try and play a
playbook that's not gonna work and I
think that's what's nice is really
getting the feedback and understanding
like why people follow you and what
behaviors work for you and also seeing
their different types of leadership play
out yeah and just to add on to what
everybody said one of the first things
that I thought about during that
question is vulnerability and openness
as well which I think just speaks to how
Stanford has hid this concept home for
everybody on repeated basis and just to
provide an example of of how that's
incorporated or curriculum one of the
classes that I'm taking right now is
called interpersonal dynamics aka
touchy-feely and it's really one of the
cornerstone classes of the GSB
experience and it's essentially a class
in which you learn all the different
models and concepts on how to understand
how to communicate with others and why
breakdowns in communications happen
why conflicts occur between people and
part of the class is literally sitting
in a room with 13 other people in a
circle for three hours at a time and
just letting the communication unfold
and it sounds super ambiguous and
unstructured but I've only had I've had
two classes so far and it's been
absolutely riveting to just sit and to
just sit in like this group and just see
how
communication unfolds and and taking
risks and expressing how you actually
feel is such a out of the comfort zone
for me but I'm kind of understanding now
how that would make me a better leader
in the future
so a lot of things that were unexpected
for me coming into the GSB about
leadership but I'm definitely learning a
lot so I we have about 10 minutes or so
left so I think we can answer a few
other questions there's a question from
the audience around how being LGBTQ has
informed how you show up and be present
in the classroom so does anyone have any
thoughts about if you made a
contribution that was informed by your
identity or whether you viewed something
a different way or brought a new
perspective because you were LGBTQ any
experiences like that in the classroom
or in group meetings I guess not in
particular in the classroom but I guess
we can talk about is talk yeah so talk
is like a weekly event in which we get
two of our classmates to seek speak in
front of the whole student body and
share maybe for 30 to 45 minutes just
their life story and whatnot yeah and I
guess so I had my talk last quarter and
you three attended thank you it was way
it was fantastic so I had my talk last
quarter and that just gave me a venue to
like tell people about my identity in my
journey to the GSB and like my journey
in life this far and a lot of that like
involved my identity as a queer person
and I feel like that just served as a
venue for me to like just share my life
story to everyone and hopefully people
queer or not queer were able to like
just pick something from that yeah I
think for me something that I think
about is sort of coming into school you
know I very much played a role at work
doing kind of turn around and crisis and
it was very much relatively straight
faced and I was there to do a specific
thing and I think I came into the
classroom a little bit like that
thinking like this is business I this is
business school like let's talk about
what
the cases in front of us and then what
I've seen is all my classmates bringing
in this wider perspective around who
they are as a person and and now
identity in bringing that to the
conversations that were having and I've
seen how powerful that's been and so I
think less and less my disconnecting Who
I am and what I'm doing and bringing
more of myself to those conversations
into the classroom so I think for me
it's still a process that I'm going
through but I've definitely seen how
it's been impactful in the conversations
that we've been having yeah and I can
just talk from my I did not personally
do this but I know of someone who who
made a an informed comment in class
where it was our marketplaces class and
the we were talking about dating apps as
a form of marketplaces and someone that
I know actually you know raised her hand
and pointed out to the professor in the
classroom that you know we're looking at
dating apps from a very heteronormative
perspective and we should also consider
the implications of a marketplace for
for a queer queer dating app or like
tinder or or you know like same-sex
dating app so it was a really insightful
I found that to be a super super
insightful comment and to be a very
brave comment as well but I could
literally see people's faces changing in
the room from to just being curious but
to just a broader understanding of like
oh these are issues that we actually
need to think about and we need to be
aware of when when talking about the
real world so I thought that was a
really really cool experience that I've
witnessed recently I think
another question this one is a little
bit more about social life at the GSB
LGBTQ nightlife at the GSB so we can
answer this one really really quickly
because I know I was curious at least
when I was playing is how is LGBTQ
nightlife near the GSB what do we do
are there venues do we organize things
on campus or do we go out to San
Francisco kind of leading you guys have
that answer right now
I think one of the one of the fantastic
things about business school whether it
be you know Pride specific or non like
if you get 50 really interesting people
in a room yeah you can make a party
that's really easy to do so it's Palo
Alto the best nightlife in the world
absolutely not do you need it to be
absolutely not we have our weekly PG PG
which is our kind of happy hour pride
which we really make the most of and
enjoy and then we head up to the city
for various events or just to go and
enjoy the nightlife every few weeks
probably
I do yeah I think we go up to the city
pretty often like once or twice a month
there's a good chunk of your social life
is also traveling with your classmates
over the weekend so I would say that
that has been the constraining factor in
terms of how often we go up to the city
so not necessarily like that Palo Alto
was bad which it is but like there's
there's other stuff out there yeah I
would say it's a one question that I had
that I know that some others might have
is how accessible is San Francisco
because Vince you mentioned that San
Francisco is a very welcoming City to to
people who identify as LGBTQ and it
absolutely is San Francisco is super
super accessible from Palo Alto you can
either take a public transport taste if
I could train there and it gets you
there in like correct me if I'm wrong
like 35 minutes 35 minutes to an hour or
if it's at night and you and you want to
go to experience in the nightlife I know
that we kind of just pile into an uber
and split the uber four ways and it
winds up to being really really a can
taking their back sometimes you take a
bus surprise we've done as events as
well where women come with other schools
and other grads kind of students and and
we've gone up and done kind of bigger
organized trips up to the city embarked
as well yeah for sure
so we have five minutes left so I want
to end on one question and that's what
do you find most rewarding so far about
the Stanford experience Jack do you I do
yeah it's my ons as a Kapow answer it's
really easy it's the people yeah and I
think you are basically surrounded by
420 classmates who have your back are
really really interesting care deeply
about one or many things that they're
passionate about and so I think the most
rewarding thing is how my mind has been
opened up to so many opportunities and
so many interesting conversations and
how those friendships and relationships
are only gonna continue to grow whether
that be from a professional perspective
or personal perspective I think the most
rewarding part is getting to do it with
this group of people especially these
guys apart from ya
Jack put it very well my answer my first
answer would definitely be the people
the network you could get out of the
business school experience but for me
personally I think what I gained from
the GSB most thus far is just being able
to explore gaming as a long-term career
because like having had like multiple
conversations with different people
about gaming potentially interning for a
gaming company this summer really like
solidified my hypothesis or like my
thesis of like trying to test whether I
want to do gaming in the long term and I
feel that if I hadn't gone to the GSB I
wouldn't even be trying to pursue this
thing long term so that has potentially
this that may have potentially dictated
what I'm gonna do for the rest of my
life and I think that's very valuable
oh another thing we were talking about
is the opportunity to take Tyra Banks
class in spring she's he's lurking
around campus right now somewhere some
people saw her 30 minutes ago so I would
also echo like the people are absolutely
critical and I have been tremendous
people here who are friendly caring
interesting super nice so I would say
that it's top I think for be also type
is a huge thing in terms of you are
you're super busy the MBA program but
you have taught a lot of time for self
reflection for career exploration to
learn about anything you want
essentially what's great about the GSB
is you can also take classes outside the
GSB at other schools in Stanford so it's
basically a two-year opportunity to meet
great people learn super interesting
things and just reflect on who you are
as a person and what you value yeah and
and just to wrap up for the group before
we go I think the most rewarding part
about the Stanford experience for me is
having an opportunity to take risks in a
low risk environment so before coming to
the GSB I would consider myself a really
really risk-averse person both in the
work in the workplace but also in my
personal life and just we've only been
at the GSB for what like seven months
now and it's completely changed my
perspective on what it means to take
risks so I'm doing activities that I
would never have done before outside of
the GSB like I'm taking a swim class
when I had no idea how to swim before
I'm testing new ways to express myself
I'm testing new ways to communicate with
others almost on a daily basis and it's
really really exciting and scary at
times but it's all for the learning and
I can't stress this enough that being at
Stanford is a lower-risk environment and
they really cultivate you to learn how
to be a person that takes risks and
that's been by far in a way the
biggest benefit so far in my first year
so we'll see what well what's in store
for us in our second year but I'm really
really excited for that and sad as well
that we're almost halfway through our
experience together but anyway I think
that's all the time that we have today
so thank you to the three of you for for
coming and participating
thank you everyone in the audience for
for tuning in to the live webcast you
can learn more about the MBA program by
visiting the GSB website at GSB
stanford.edu and I think that's it for
us
Oh also if you have questions about the
pride group feel free to email GSB
underscore pride leadership at
stanford.edu as well but thank you again
and have a great day
[Music]